hey guys pete here i've been working on
my follow-up video in the proto-molecule
series but have to stop the work
temporarily because there's some pretty
promising news
the authors of the expanse series have
declined to call the news that season
six would be the last
a cancellation they prefer to call it a
pause
they say that's where the story's at a
natural pause
and that's a word that a lot of fans
have been throwing around
ever since the announcement of season
six happen if you were devastated that
we might not be able to see the final
three books play out on screen
i'm here to tell you there's hope and
make no mistake it's the kind of hope
that goes beyond wish fulfillment from
fans
how far beyond that well that's up for
debate i did have one more preview video
i was working on for season five so i'm
gonna go ahead and mash those two things
together
in this video i'll get into what the
authors said and then preview where all
the major factions in the story
earth mars and the belt where they're at
going into the season
the early season 5 reviews from critics
are in and they appear to be really
positive
there's a new clip from episode 3 of
naomi arriving at palace station
and an announcement that ty frank and
west chatham will be doing an after show
podcast that looks fantastic
before we get started this will contain
spoilers for everything that's happened
in the expanse tv show
including all the season 5 promo
materials that have been released
i'll be referring to the books while
avoiding future spoilers there
if any of that scares you away please
consider subscribing on your way out i'm
a big fan of the expanse i'm going to be
putting out content throughout the
season
and you probably won't see most of it
when the bigger channels swoop in so any
support is appreciated
so with that out of the way let's get
started for the news that the writers
don't consider the show cancelled
polygon is reporting that tai had this
to say at a recent press event for the
new season
we have what we think is a very natural
pause point for the story after season
six
it'll feel like a satisfying end to the
story we've been building over the first
five
seasons i think one of the things that
is sort of an outmoded idea
is the idea of being cancelled that in
itself isn't much but he continues
saying
alcon our studio is very committed to
the ip
they have lots of plans we'll see what
happens after that
but we will have a satisfying story to
the tv arc in the sixth season
his writing partner daniel abraham
finished off with this
this is a conversation we've been having
since we were cancelled the first time
we've been talking about what the shape
of the show could be and this six season
arc was always one of the options on the
table
this is not something that we're having
to scramble for we built something to
shape and it's kind of awesome that we
get to do something that's this shape
because we didn't we didn't have one of
those that was five seasons long
my takeaway to all of that is this they
knew going in it was probably going to
be a long shot to be able to do nine
full seasons
ending at season five would have been a
worst case scenario because it would
have been a cliffhanger
the books could be described as three
duologies in a final trilogy
books one and two go together books
three and four go together
and this is most notable in five and six
and in that way i would have to agree
if you were planning things you'd have
to put the option of ending at book six
on the table
in my previous video on the season six
announcement i brought this up and while
none of this
really adds up to them saying that they
know that there's more expanse in the
future
it is reassuring that they've been
thinking about ending the story at six
and have what they feel will be a
satisfying ending the one major problem
i see with this
is that we have this overarching
narrative of the proto-molecule
it's been driving the story so i think
that show only fans will be expecting an
answer to what that was all about but
we'll be in a lot better of a position
to speculate on that after we see the
ending of season 5 in a couple months
i guess the most exciting nugget in this
polygon article
is that the studio alcon have other
expanse
related ideas that they want to do this
will likely feel like a confirmation to
all the fans who were
convinced that this 30-year gap that
exists between books six and seven
which is a real thing that happens that
that was the reason they were stopping
at season six that it was a big master
plan to stop for a few years
to let the actors age into their future
roles
then they could come back and do books
seven through nine in
a film trilogy for me i think that's
still kind of optimistic
they aren't saying that at least right
now maybe they will say something like
that
before season six wraps up i think it's
a great idea i'd love to see it
the scale of the final three books
really is impressive
so i would love to see them throw piles
of money at that and to produce that on
the kind of scale that my mind imagines
it at
but at that point we are getting into
that area of fan wish fulfillment what
he says is that alcon
is committed to the ip and they have
lots of plans
i don't think that's something he would
just throw out there lightly but
officially i think we have to say that
we don't really know what the future
looks like i'd be happy to discuss and
debate that in the comments
i have ideas i'm sure you do too so to
wrap this section
up i say there is hope i think first and
foremost
we can't expect that they have an idea
that they feel will be satisfying to
complete the tv series as we know it and
then they're not ruling out the fact
that we might be able to see
more of the story in the future so now
getting back to season five
which i was in the middle of writing a
lot of words about for a final preview
considering i just spent five minutes
talking about all this other stuff i'm
gonna condense that down
into something pretty succinct here and
just wrap up
where the different factions are going
into the fifth season
in my other preview videos i've been
talking a lot about this idea of the
crew getting spread out
and it makes for an exciting time in the
book series the rossi's returning the
soul system
after traveling to illis on behalf of
avasarala
because some refugees had settled there
and they came across a lot of
proto-molecule artifacts
which as we know holden and the crew
have a lot of experience
with we've seen in the preview materials
that they end up at tycho's station
we know naomi has picked up chatter her
ex marco inaros
who's also the father of her son is
stirring things up
and she's told holden that she's gonna
leave to go look for phillip
and she doesn't want him to come along
amos is gonna take this time to go back
to earth to deal with some personal
business
and we've also seen in the season five
trailer that alex makes his way back to
mars at this time
and we see him interacting with bobby so
that means that we'll have naomi and
holden both
in the belt but separate holding at
tycho station
and we have a new clip of naomi arriving
at palace station
where she runs into some old friends and
this is exciting for reasons that i
can't say without giving book spoilers
but this clip in particular does show
how this idea of splitting them
up can add so much to the characters in
this season
in this clip we see naomi being a belter
she's not only just around other belters
but she's away from the crew and you can
see how her personality
and even her accent shifts when she's
talking with them
at this point in the story we already
like these characters we spent enough
time with them that were invested so
while splitting them up might seem like
a problem
i think if they're able to capture what
they did in the books it really takes
things up to the next level
so these two characters are in the belt
and then the other two crew members
are in mars and earth respectively so
let's talk about the belt
first the opening of the ring gate and
then subsequently the ring network
really does change things in sol system
forever as far as the belt's concerned
a lot of the people who have gone there
and have adapted to living in low g
are going to find that a lot of the
resource extraction that they do
isn't nearly as important as it used to
be because you have 1300 new worlds
so that's a whole lot of new
opportunities where they can produce
those same resources
this is exasperated by the fact that
they have adapted to life in low g
and so only about two-thirds of them
will be able to go down to the surface
of one of these planets and adapt
and that's with the right medication
regime and a lot of preparation
we saw that naomi wasn't even able to
pull that off on illus
and she's generally in pretty good shape
so naturally since the ring gate is
way out past uranus the best bet that
the residents of the belt
have is to set themselves up in a
position to monitor the traffic going
out to all those new colony planets
the plan is to convert the behemoth
which used to be the nauvoo
into a station that permanently resides
near the hub of the rings
we know the belt has several different
factions and they don't all get along
or agree but for simplicity we could
kind of put them in two categories
we have the category that thinks that
the best path forward
is to form an alliance with the inner
planets and on the other side
the group that thinks that the belters
should control the ring space
without having to answer to the inner
planets broadly this is going to come
down to fred johnson's faction of the
opa
and marco anaris's more extreme faction
the free navy
and we had plenty of hints in season
four that marco has something going on
with a group of martians
so that is what the belt will be dealing
with and holden and naomi will be out
there and will likely get sucked into it
as far as mars where bobby and alex will
be the reality is is that well it's kind
of over
the conflict with earth and their
involvement in the proto-molecule has
caused
problems but the opening of the ring
gate really is the big issue
mars has been embarking on a generations
long terraforming project and with 1300
habitable worlds out there
it really doesn't make the sense that it
used to this has been the thing that has
defined martians
the original people who colonized it
created this dream
they were willing to live underground in
tunnels for the hope that someday they
would create a whole new world
as time goes on people got used to
living in the tunnels that's all they've
ever known
they never lived on earth they're used
to living inside domes
it's been nearly 150 years since the
epstein drive was invented
so they never even lived as colonists of
earth so the big picture idea
is less important to them and we saw in
the last season that a lot of the people
are already looking to jump ship
now i went into this in a lot more
detail in my season 4 recap but the
bottom line is that when real
colonization happens when people start
to go through all the gates
the dream of mars and the terraforming
project will inevitably
fall out of favor on earth things aren't
quite as bad
we know that avasarala lost her election
she's no longer in charge
and her enthusiasm for colonization is
one of the big factors and why nancy gao
won
earth has a lot of problems
overpopulation
historically there's been environmental
disasters
half of the population are on basic
assistance there's not enough jobs to go
around
so you can understand that the citizens
are looking for something to change
their conditions
avasarala was against this because she
knew what a bloodbath a gold rush could
turn into
but as far as where things are in the
beginning of season 5
the real threat for earth is this attack
that marco inaros is planning with the
asteroid
so we have amos returning he'll be there
as that all goes down
and we'll see if marco's able to use
this opportunity where he sees earth as
weak
to strike at them and change the balance
of the three factions for good
and for the proto-molecule it'll be
interesting to see what they do
there isn't really a lot of movement in
that story during book five
when holden destroyed the proto-molecule
that was left on the rossi
he cut his connection with proto miller
that part of the story is over for now
there is still one active proto-molecule
sampled the one that they gave fred
johnson
and we did see in that first clip that
they're at least gonna be talking about
the unknown aggressors
the civilization that they believe
destroyed the civilization that created
the proto-molecule
so i suppose they're gonna be moving
some of that up but at this point we
really don't know how far they're gonna
get into that in season six
we'll have to wait till after we see
season five and we can speculate
from there it's all really exciting and
after reading the early reviews of the
season
i think this really is going to be the
best season we've ever seen
book 5 has some of the most amazing
moments in the entire series
and i just have to say that i can't wait
to see how it all turns out
i'm gonna leave it there let me know in
the comments what you think about the
season six news
what you think about season five i'll
definitely continue making videos
throughout the season
so i hope you'll join along with me as
we go through it let me know any
questions you have
anything you're thinking about and if
you're gonna talk about future books
please mark those book spoilers please
like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon